Even if our ancestors
consumed a full spectrum
of vitamins and minerals every day,
mouths would very likely
still grow too small.
What was true for our ancestors
was also true for us,
because the problem had less
to do with what we were eating
than how we ate it, chewing.
It was the constant stress of chewing
that was lacking from our diets,
not specifically vitamins A, B, C, or D.
95% of the industrialized diet was soft.
Our ancient ancestors chewed
for hours a day, every day.
Because they chewed so much,
their mouths, their teeth,
their throats, and their faces
grew to be wide and strong and pronounced.
This larger mouth with straighter teeth
allowed them to breathe more easily.
Food in industrialized
societies was so processed
that it hardly required
any chewing at all.
Here's some of the industrialized mush
that I grew up eating.
Yes, of course I had extractions.
Yes, of course I needed
braces and headgear
and everything else.
Here's the typical modern
American diet today.
Cheese sauces, baked goods,
spaghetti, fried roots.
It's all soft.
Even what's considered healthy
foods, smoothies, yogurt,
avocados, oatmeal, it's all soft.
Healthy chewing starts in infancy.
The chewing and sucking stress
required for breastfeeding
exercises the masseter
and other facial muscles,
and stimulates more bone growth,
allowing for that upper palate to drop,
which leads to wider airways.
Until a few hundred years ago,
mothers would breastfeed
infants up to two to four years,
sometimes even longer.
The more time infants
spent chewing and sucking,
the more they'd increase their
chances of breathing better
later on in life.
With industrialization came
bottle-feeding and baby formula.
Soon, in many societies,
infants were hardly breastfed at all.
Now, dozens and dozens of studies
in the past two decades
have supported this claim.
They've shown lower incidence
of snoring and sleep apnea
in infants who are breastfed longer
versus those who are bottle-fed.
This is why so many of the
skulls that I've examined
in the Museum of Archeology
and Anthropology,
that I'd seen at the Paris quarries,
this is why they had narrow
faces and crooked teeth.
It's one of the main reasons
why so many of us today
are chronically stuffed-up,
why our airways are
clogged, why we need sprays
and pills and surgery,
just to get a fresh breath of air.